mais je crois qu'en France l'intégrisme
catholique c'est quelque chose que qu'on
sous-estime et qui risque sérieusement
de faire parler de lui
Serge Grünberg et Jean-Marc Barbieux
vous avez fait pour globe pour le numéro
qui sort en février une enquête qui
s'appelle voyage en intégrie suite à
l'attaque du cinéma à Saint-Michel par
un par un groupe d'intégristes et suite
à l'attaque dont a été victime Hélène
Delaveau au bouffe du Nord ça va vous
valoir une interview
on va commencer par le début mais
monseignir Lefebvre Lefevre c'est
marrant on a l'impression que tout
autour tout tourne autour de Monseigneur
le faire et on se rend compte que
finalement tout le monde dit que mousser
dans le fer est vide
il est largué il est vieux quoi il est
vieux tout le monde attend qui casse et
qui va qui va le remplacer quand il va
casser sa mite comme tu dis
c'est simple
des héritiers potentiels il a fait
beaucoup parler de lui surtout à
l'époque du détail de Jean-Marie Le Pen
pourquoi parce que tu es d'accord lui
oui il était d'accord il faut dire
quelque chose c'est que à chaque fois
qu'on a parlé avec des intégries de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale par exemple pour
eux l'épisode le plus horrible de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale c'est en gros ce
qui s'est passé à les libérations c'est
l'épuration chacun un silence comme ça
pour eux ils ont un peu l'attitude
disons neutralise quoi c'est à dire que
c'est un peu l'attitude de Franco de
salazariste
pour le maréchal Pétain alors dans
Gérard c'est un personnage étonnant
parce que un jour donc vous occupez de
lui puis vous voyez débarquer Mobutu et
dont on sait qu'il a fait remplacer les
noms chrétiens des des habitants du
Congo par des noms africains et
finalement il fait le voyage il va dans
le c'est dans le Midi qui est installé
dans Gérard non tout près du Mont
Ventoux alors don Gérard c'est un peu le
Walt Disney de l'intégrisme
il est en train de faire construire deux
immenses couvents en style néo-roman on
est en plein dans le passé et
il a une cinquantaine de moines on nous
a précisé que beaucoup étaient d'anciens
Saint-Cyriens effectivement ce sont des
moines sommedats des nouveaux croisés
parce qu'on voit toujours des toujours
des affiches dans les rues avec des des
Labé de Nantes c'est qui s'est tapé de
Nantes c'est quelqu'un pour le situer un
peu une de ces positions les plus hardes
ça a été de dire qu'il refusait de
défiler contre l'avortement parce que
les manifestations contre l'avortement
se faisaient au nom de la liberté et que
pour lui la liberté c'est le désordre
il avait prévu la fin du monde pour 83
on est toujours là on est toujours là
romain Marie alias Bernard Anthony il
faut quand même préciser qu'il a été sur
les listes de Le Pen pour les élections
européennes et qu'il est très proche du
Front National et en ce moment
les torchon de brûle un peu entre les
intégristes et Le Pen je crois
d'ailleurs je vais utiliser nos photos
pour la campagne
moi j'ai une petite
théorie c'est que Le Pen aime beaucoup
se faire prendre en photo à côté du pape
et alors s'il suit monseigneur le fait
jusqu'au bout fini les photos avec le
parc la famille ah justement parce que
c'est dans la famille a donc vous taisez
le nom c'est pas dans cette famille on
vous explique que finalement si
Jean-Paul II a pu sortir de de Pologne
c'est parce qu'en fait c'est un agent du
KGB il appelle l'autre
oui les intégrer se vivent un peu dans
le dans la hantise du complot alors il y
a deux grands complots un complot
maçonnique les francs-maçons et en
complot communiste et on nous a donc
expliqué ce qui revient très très
souvent dans les discussions que si les
Russes ont laissé sortir Jean-Paul II de
Pologne c'est forcément que c'est un
agent à eux donc Jean-Paul II communiste
le comte de ricoman c'est celui qui t'a
repéré ça pendant que je sais pas où tu
étais parti il a dit à Barbieux dis donc
Grimbert il a un drôle de nom là quand
même rappelez-moi appelez-moi le nom de
la famille
avec une famille très je lui ai dit que
ça s'écrivait un thé quoi et alors d'un
seul coup
de haricots on lui a donné
Sainte-Clotilde alors lui il fait pas la
messe depuis 5 que la messe de Paul VI
oui alors il y a des nuances qui
échappent un peu au profane c'est le cas
de le dire
le compte de ecommande nous a dit
lui-même que même des gens très éclairés
en cette matière
c'était trompé ils avaient pris la messe
de Paul VI pour la messe de Paul 6 et ça
passe très bien
en plus ou moins quoi disons que
François Brignoud comme il le dit
lui-même d'ailleurs et toute cette
mouvance autour d'eux se situe dans ce
qu'ils appellent la tendance nationale
catholique alors je sais pas si ça
évoque quelque chose mais national
catholique
pas loin d'autres choses
et Pierre si dose
alors ça ça me rappelle ma jeunesse au
Quartier Latin pierre sido maintenant
est devenu vraiment un national
catholique d'ailleurs en meeting de
l'anti 89 il se faisait présenter comme
le fils d'un ministre du maréchal c'est
vrai ça
doit être alors pierre si Doze
maintenant mimite avec des skins des ELS
Angels pour le national catholicisme
justement il y a un personnage dans
votre article assez étonnant c'est ils
vont le tatouer là parce que ce qui
ce qui est terrible c'est que maintenant
on voit des l ça avec des avec des
Harley et puis qui ont des cœurs souvent
sur la boisson
et tout ça c'est quelque chose qui sort
un petit peu côté cowboy et
c'est une récupération du cow-boy à la
française le chevalier quoi
et vous avez rencontré Jacques dufilo en
faisant votre enquête aussi oui très
curieux alors Jacques dufilo je savais
déjà qu'il se définissait comme un
paysan mais c'est un paysan dans la
définir comme un paysan en soi c'est pas
non mais enfin j'ai l'impression qu'il
passe quand même plus de temps sur les
planches que dans un champ mais c'est un
paysan qui a fait aussi Saumur donc
toute cette tradition française
alors ce que j'ai retenu surtout chez
Jacques dufilo c'est que lui n'aime pas
beaucoup les Orléans ils nous ont même
carrément dit les Orléans ce sont des
assassins il y a un truc qui est très
étonnant dans votre papier c'est qu'il y
en a qui vous soutiennent que
Jésus-Christ n'était pas juif par
exemple parce qu'ils ont du mal admettre
en tant que que catholique que
Jésus-Christ ait pu être juif par
exemple ça a commencé tout de suite
quand j'ai eu des conversations devant
le cinéma Saint-Michel qui avait brûlé
il y a deux intérêts comme ça qui
m'avaient repéré et qui m'ont dit et si
on faisait un film sur Abraham en train
de faire des cochonneries sans entourage
alors je leur disais mais vous savez
dans la Bible il se passe des tas de
choses horribles regardez le roi Salomon
etc je leur disais mais vous savez Jésus
descend de David et de Salomon ils m'ont
dit ah non non pas du tout donc quand
Jean-Paul II visite une synagogue pour
eux c'est parce que c'est un agent du
KGB quoi ah oui absolument pour eux tout
ce qui n'est pas strictement catholique
apostolique et Romain et banni mais
alors ce qui est curieux c'est que
justement Monseigneur Lefebvre est fait
un schisme au nom de sa fidélité à
l'église enfin c'est des contradictions
avec lesquelles ils ont l'air de avoir
fait un papier uniquement sur le
s'appelle voyage en intégré mais
pourquoi uniquement sur les intégristes
ils ont catholiques parce que les
intégristes juifs qui à New York exemple
refuse l'État d'Israël parce que ça ils
sont pas d'accord ou même dans certains
quartiers à Paris ou même en France des
intégristes musulmans pourquoi seulement
sont sans prendre déjà elle est à New
York ou enfin j'ai pas eu envie de faire
un papier sur l'intégrisme en général
parce que l'intégrisme c'est à quelque
chose qui est propre tout à l'heure
c'est que 89 ça l'intérêt de catalyser à
la fois les spirituelle disons genre
Lefèvre et des vieux briscards de
l'extrême droite qui reviennent et qui
qui retrouvent une nouvelle jeunesse je
dois dire que l'intégrisme tel qu'il se
présente maintenant c'est quelque chose
de typiquement France il y a un
intégrisme protestant comme aux
États-Unis ils sont presque 40 millions
il y a un intégrisme juif on a vu ça aux
dernières élections israéliennes mais je
crois qu'en France l'intégrisme
catholique c'est quelque chose que qu'on
sous-estime et qui risque sérieusement
de faire parler de lui dans les semaines
qui l'enquête vous pensez qu'il y a un
vrai danger
avant la sortie de l'enquête et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu